der von corona und den maßnahmen sind
wirklich alle bereiche betroffen
darunter auch die kulturbranche etliche
künstler innen mussten alles absagen
oder verschieben und wissen zudem nicht
wann es weitergeht wie es überhaupt
weitergehen soll
denn dazu bräuchte es lösungen und die
gibt es auf den ersten blick nicht oder
nicht so richtig aber eine studie soll
helfen sie will herausfinden wie man vor
tausenden zuschauer innen spielen kann
ohne zum corona super sprayer event zu
werden mein gast im eins zu eins hilft
der wissenschaft bei der suche nach
einer antwort nicht ganz uneigennützig
denn er ist musiker und dann seht ihr
den leben auf die füße wohnzimmerkonzert
online statt auftritt im stadion
sämtliche konzerte des 35 jährigen
sängers tim bendzko sind auf das nächste
jahr verschoben wegen corona die
deutsche kulturlandschaft schlägt alarm
so wie hier am vergangenen sonntag in
berlin
artisten tänzer schauspielerinnen sie
alle leben von auftritten vor publikum
unmöglich seit die pandemie mitte märz
deutschland erreichte
von der politik fühlen sie sich im stich
gelassen
wir sind leider nicht so ein
geschlossener block wie so ein konzern
wie die lufthansa zum beispiel und in
dem sinne brauchen wir eine monatliche
unterstützung
[Musik]
knapp 436.000 kulturschaffende in
deutschland sind selbstständig aber
nicht nur die künstler auf der bühne
sondern auch die verantwortlichen hinter
den kulissen trifft die korona krise mit
voller wucht massenveranstaltungen wie
rock am ring zurzeit undenkbar
konzertveranstalter marek lieberberg
will der ganzen branche und den
verwaisten hallen wieder neues leben
einhauchen im september plant er mit
rund 13.000 zuschauern das bisher größte
konzert wir brauchen dringend jetzt ein
solches hoffnungszeichen für eine
branche die am boden liegt und es sind
nicht nur wir die veranstalter es sind
150.000 menschen bühnenarbeiter
techniker busfahrer caterer wir wollen
diejenigen sein die ein kleines bisschen
hoffnung in diese sehr sehr trübe
situation bringen und diese situation
ist existenziell
trotz eines strengen hygiene konzeptes
werden seine konzertpläne in der politik
intensiv diskutiert das problem kaum
einer weiß bisher wie groß das
infektionsrisiko bei großveranstaltungen
ist genau das will ein experiment der
universität halle jetzt herausfinden
hier in leipzig soll sänger tim bendzko
in gut einer woche vor 4000 zuschauern
auftreten für alle teilnehmer gelten
strenge hygiene regeln und sie werden
vorher getestet
wir messen hauptsächlich während der
ganzen veranstaltung kontakte und dazu
kriegt jeder unserer teilnehmer so einen
kleinen trailer ist etwa so groß wird
mit einem schlüsselband hier umgegangen
und wir wollen mal genauer nachschauen
hier in geschützter umgebung wo
entstehen denn eigentlich die
gefährdungs momente denn das sind ja die
informationen die wir danach brauchen um
solche veranstaltungen besser und
sicherer zu machen
ein konzert für die wissenschaft auf
deren erkenntnisse setzt eine ganze
branche und natürlich künstler wie tim
bendzko damit konzerte wie diese
irgendwann wieder möglich sind
[Musik]
es wird die erste studie dieser art
weltweit sein und er macht mit tim
bendzko schirm guten abend sagt tim und
eines vielleicht kurz vorweg wir kennen
uns schon relativ langen deswegen sind
wir beim du und bleiben einfach auch
dabei bevor wir gleich über die studie
sprechen vielleicht einmal kurz wie hast
du die korona zeit bis hier her erlebt
für dich ja es ist natürlich anfänglich
total bitter gewesen weil wir kurz davor
standen natur zu spielen und wie bei
allen anderen auch wurden alle meine
konzerte aufs nächste jahr verschoben
und das ist natürlich initial erstmal
sehr unangenehme diesen vor alle
beteiligten dann was eigentlich ganz
schön mal so lange am selben ort zu sein
und nicht ständig unterwegs zu sein und
dann wird es aber auch schnell wieder
privat nicht so schön wenn man ja auch
seine familie ist nicht sehen konnte
seine freundin nicht sehen konnte aber
da ging es mir wahrscheinlich wie allen
anderen auch
und auf der anderen seite privilegiert
weil du natürlich die gewisse zeit auch
überbrücken kannst also jedenfalls was
das finanzielle anbelangt aber darauf
kommen wir später noch zu sprechen viele
andere eben dann auch nicht mal zur
studie also die findet jetzt am 22
august in leipzig statt du machst spiels
im grunde drei konzerte a 20 minuten
warum machst du da überhaupt mit ich
glaube einfach dass das für die gesamte
veranstaltungsbranche und allen branchen
die irgendwie davon partizipieren
essentiell ist dass wir schnell wieder
richtung normalität kommen
und dahin zu kommen braucht man planen
und für den plan ist es natürlich
irgendwie wichtig zu wissen wie es sich
denn wirklich verhält bei so einer
veranstaltung und ich hoffe dass die
studie da ein bisschen licht ins dunkle
bringen kann weil wir da versuchen
werden herauszufinden wie an so einem
veranstaltungstag oder wo die stellen
sind wo besondere gefahren bestehen
damit man dann eben für gewisse konzepte
die entsprechenden konsequenzen ziehen
kann damit wir alle schnell wieder
sicher an großveranstaltungen teilnehmen
könnt das ganze ist kostenlos auch wenn
man mit der s-bahn oder oben hin fährt
auch das wird irgendwie glaube ich schon
schon mitgenommen
die anmeldezahlen sind jetzt noch nicht
da wo sie sein sollen als noch nicht
ausverkauft hast du eine ahnung woran
das
liegt ja ich glaube es ist bei den
nachrichten die ich so bekomme große
unsicherheit
es wird natürlich alles dafür getan dass
wieder vor ort alle sicher sind jeder
wird ein crooner test vorher machen
müssen alle werden währenddessen maske
tragen kriegen desinfektions gel mit dem
sie sich ständig die hände reiben müssen
wir versuchen dass alle so sicher wie
irgendwie möglich sind weil es uns nicht
darum geht und versuche am menschen zu
machen sondern mit den menschen einfach
her zu gucken wie sie sich vor ort
bewegen und die angst muss man glaube
ich einfach ein bisschen nehmen und du
hast dich natürlich mit den experten die
diese studie begleiten ausgetauscht bis
da gut informiert rücken die dann schon
mal mit seiner prognose raus also womit
rechnen sie waren es wirklich wieder
losgehen könnte keiner also keine ahnung
wie das im detail aussieht und ich
glaube dass das auch gar nicht
ziel der studie ist am ende sagen zu
können an dem tag könnt ihr wieder
spielen sondern es geht hatte ich im
detail darum eben überhaupt konzept wie
möglich zu machen die uns erstmal
anfangen ermöglichen also es gibt jetzt
wieder die möglichkeit dass die gut
studie gut ausgeht oder dass sie
schlecht ausgeht sondern wenn wir jetzt
einfach darum dass er überhaupt konzepte
machen können die uns eine normalität
erlauben die eine gewisse kapazität
zulässt weil die kapazitäten bedingt
jetzt konzerte gespielt werden ob das
auto kino konzerte sind oder picken die
konzerte auch gemacht
das ist an sich schön für alle
beteiligten für die zuschauer war für
uns als band aber es sind halt leider
nicht wirtschaftlich jetzt weh des
bundes nicht schlimmer wird was die
pandemie anbelangt ein anderes konzert
geben mit sarah connor und noch zwei
weiteren mindestens vier weiteren
künstlerinnen da sollen pi mal daumen
13.000 zuschauer in dabei sein was
hältst du davon
ja ich sehe das so ein bisschen
zweigeteilt auf der einen seite ist es
natürlich ein unglaublich wichtiges
zeichen aufmerksamkeit darauf zu legen
dass die veranstaltungsbranche dringend
wieder zur normalität muss auf der
anderen seite ist das problem so ein
bisschen dass das auch eine
veranstaltung ist die nicht
wirtschaftlich ist
weil eine große halle oder ein großes
stadion das kostet genauso viel wenn da
nur zehn prozent der leute drin sind die
da reinpassen und das genau was wir
gerade haben sieht so ein bisschen so
aus als würde das alles wieder anlaufen
aber de facto ist es in der
veranstaltungsbranche
der stand heute genau der gleiche wie im
lock down
es ist gerade nicht wirtschaftlich
konzerte zu spielen wenn man nicht eine
gewisse kapazität an zuschauern zum
lässt mich hat es ja eingangs schon
gesagt also wenn wir über künstler
entsprechen dann geht es eben um dich
und und anderen namen die einem sofort
in den kopf kommen aber eigentlich so
gut wie niemand denkt an die frau bands
an djs an all die leute die eigentlich
gebraucht werden um eine bühne
aufzubauen am ton an licht also das ist
never ending story was wünscht du dir da
ja genau das ist ein bisschen das
problem verbindet mit der veranstaltungs
und eventbranche die leute die man im
fernsehen sieht aber der viel größere
teil wahrscheinlich 99,9 prozent der
leute sieht man ihm fernsehen das sind
alle die hinter den kulissen die das
überhaupt erst möglich machen und um die
geht es das sind die die alle gerade um
ihre existenz kämpfen und irgendwie
deshalb sitze ich hier und bin noch teil
dieser studie aber was wünscht du dir
also was was bräuchten die jetzt zb
bräuchte es auch ein eigenes größeres
nochmal konjunkturpaket oder war also
die am ende gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder wir finden sehr sehr schnell
eine möglichkeit wieder mit
entsprechenden kapazitäten konzerte zu
spielen oder sport veranstaltung zu
machen oder es muss von einer politik
kompensiert werden ansonsten sieht sehr
sehr viele schwarz aus hast du denn mit
deinen künstler eine mit denen schon
lange zusammenarbeit ist hast du
versucht den in irgendeiner form zu
helfen hat also meine band und ich wir
haben wir viele auto kino konzerte
gespielt und das ist da sich der
hauptgrund gewesen warum wir das gemacht
haben das ist auch kostendeckend gewesen
im besten fall und das damit hat sich
ausschließlich gemacht über folgende art
und weise den auswahl unserer konzerte
zu kompensieren und jetzt mit der studie
erhoffst du dir auch das erst mal die
leute kommen dass es dann gut geht dass
es dann schnell wieder los geht und dass
es auch vielleicht auf den fußball zu
übertragen ist du bist nämlich fc bayern
münchen fan würde tatsächlich auch
wieder gerne ins fußballstadion aber das
ist gerade dich meine hauptpriorität ich
hoffe sehr dass die studie auch so ein
bisschen aus natürlich dass sie uns
ergebnisse liefert die dass uns die
chance gibt wieder zu spielen
hoffe aber auch dass sie so ein bisschen
an steckt und dass das hoffentlich
nachfolge studien gibt die mehr und mehr
wir haben uns möglichkeiten schaffen
sowohl im sport als auch irgendwie in
der kunst
wieder auf die bühne zu kommen und wer
mitmachen will muss sich beeilen noch
kann man sich ja man kann sich noch
bewerben wie start 19 ist die webseite
kann sich da einfach registrieren
es kostet nichts und ich glaube es ist
eine spannende sache da dabei zu sein
man tut mal was auch für die
gesellschaft und für die gesamte branche
und ich glaube dass das für eine
gesellschaft kunst kultur super
essentiell ist und ich habe mich einfach
total freuen wenn da so viele leute wie
möglich vorbeikommen also man tut was
gutes im hinblick auf die studie und man
kriegt tim bendzko auch noch für
unmöglich sehr kleiner events wie
konzerte in vielen dank für deinen
besuch wer gerne drücken würde und allen
anderen künstler und künstlerinnen
natürlich die daumen das ist wirklich
sehr schnell los geht dann hat er sehr